un almacén de mercancías reconvertido en
un centro de refugio temporal para niños
en el polígono industrial del tarajal en
ceuta casi 500 menores esperan en
precarias condiciones a que se decida su
futuro después de cruzar solos y nadando
la frontera marroquí todavía no he
hablado con mi madre debe estar muy
preocupada porque soy la única persona
que le da algo de comer a uno de los
chicos datos francamente mi sueño aquí
es trabajar como limpiador duermen en el
suelo sin una comida caliente al día
muchos se escapan y deambulan por las
calles del enclave español
se complique hacer o la persona que aquí
es complicado nadie viene a ayudarnos
estamos aquí dormimos en la calle
llevamos cuatro días en la calle no hay
nada nadie nos apoya así que solo
sufrimos y hay ámbito afecte a paso
activa los ingenieros dan con efe que
sufrir y siempre se han identificado
unos 800 menores de los más de 2000 que
se cree que entraron desde el pasado
lunes durante la nueva crisis migratoria
desatada en la frontera sur de europa
miles de personas fueron devueltas en
caliente no se conocen a los retornos de
migrantes al territorio
nada más pisar al suelo español de
atender el derecho a petición de asilo
algo amparado por la norma de seguridad
ciudadana de españa' o ley mordaza salvo
en el caso de menores ancianos o mujeres
embarazadas sin embargo ong en el
terreno denuncian la violación de varios
derechos humanos y devoluciones de
menores sin estudiar sus solicitudes
ante el anuncio del gobierno español de
agilizar los protocolos de repatriación
de los niños y niñas marroquíes que han
cruzado a ceuta recordamos que no puede
hacerse de forma automática se ha de
evaluar caso por caso por ahora a ceuta
se centra en la búsqueda de los padres
mientras la desesperación y el hastío se
apodera de los menores desamparados